I mean first of all I don't know how
much your kids engage with your work do
they like watching you uh no yeah did
you take advantage of the covet bubble
to say you know let's go revisit some of
Dad's early work absolutely not no they
wouldn't they wouldn't stand for it no I
have well my my 16 year old likes to
give me a hard time and she she is very
clear about not uh not wanting to see
anything that I'm in if she thinks it
might be good oh interesting yeah so
she'll watch anything she hears like if
I get bad reviews and something she's
like that's that's the one she wants to
do oh my God that is the most ice cold
16 year old thing I've ever heard I have
there's one movie I did that's not very
good uh and it's called The Great Wall
and and my daughter was talking to one
of her friends and she was talking about
this movie my dad to this movie the wall
and and she kept calling it the wall and
I was Finding like Isabella that movie's
called The Great Wall and she was like
Dad there is nothing great
okay